(crowd cheering)
- Hey, hi!
- [Kelly] I'm obsessed with this suit!
- Isn't this suit cute?
- It is so cute. You look like
rock'n'roll Prince, like...
- Oh my God. My dream to look like Prince.
- [Kelly] I, yeah, it, well, it worked.
It's happening.
- Well, that's what I'm
celebrating in the holidays,
is Prince.
- I know. I feel like every time I see you
it's the... we're celebrating holidays.
- [Amy] We are!
- So many holidays.
I'm always in a red dress when I'm...
- [Amy] Yeah.
- I swear I have other colors.
- I'm always just covered
in some kind of like,
Christmas bow, like...
- [Kelly] This is like our tradition.
- Yeah.
- Alright. So last time we were here,
you said that you were going
to dance across the country.
- I did?
- For your 50th birthday.
- Oh wow, I said that?
- How was your dance?
- I said that?
- [Kelly] How was the dance?
- I had a big dance
party. I love to dance.
We talked about this.
- I know this about you, yes.
- And I, I don't know if I said this then
but I find dancing at events and functions
a really good way to get rid of anxiety.
- Yes. Because it's awkward. Yeah.
- [Amy] Because it's
hard sometimes to talk.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- To people, even though that's your job.
One of your 10 jobs.
But, and sometimes it's like you wanna
just kind of move your body.
So I find that more... dancing relaxes me.
- Me too.
- And when you're at a party, you're like
"I can't talk right now. I have to dance."
Like, you know you have to...
- [Kelly] Yes!
- Yeah.
So I had a big dance
party for my birthday.
- I love that.
- [Amy] Yeah.
And I, yeah, I, I'm not
like a dancer per se,
but I love...
- [Amy] It doesn't matter.
- [Kelly] I love moving my body.
- Me too, me too.
- I feel it feels so good.
- I love shouting lyrics at my friends.
- Yeah. Do you ever, usually when I'm...
usually when I'm doing this,
I get all the lyrics wrong.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
It's like, oh, I didn't know those.
- That's part of the fun.
- Not even, don't even have to be drunk.
Just still don't get
them completely sober.
- Yep, yep. And if you
don't, and if you...
if you mix it up, you give like a wink.
So you're like, "I knew what it was".
- You're like, "I messed that up.
I was just being funny."
- [Amy] Yeah. I'm just doing a remix.
- I heard this about you,
which I think is funny
'cause it seems late in the game
to learn how to pluck your eyebrows,
But Tina Fey taught you?
Like, when did she...
did she teach you how
to pluck your eyebrows?
I'm like, how long have
you known each other?
- What if I was like, "44"?
- I was like, I was like...
it seemed late in the game.
Like, when did y'all meet and this happen?
- We were probably at that point,
we were probably touring
at, touring for Second City.
So I was in my twenties for sure.
- Oh, okay. Okay.
- Yeah. I was in my twenties.
- For some reason in my brain,
I just see y'all meeting at 30.
And you were like, "so
how do you do this?"
- No. You know, you know Tina and Maya,
who I do "Baking It" with and like,
we've all now known each other
for 25 years almost. So...
- That's awesome.
- Yeah. Rachel Dratch,
all those people I met,
but Tina and I met in Chicago
in the nineties, so yeah.
It must have been...
And the nineties was a
different time, you know?
- I feel like people used to
pluck all their eyebrows off
at one point.
- That's true. Yes. That's true.
- It was a very thin line.
- I have very, I've been told not to brag
but I've been told I
have very Irish eyebrows,
which means they're hardy.
- [Kelly] Yeah. I have...
- And they're kind of strong.
- I do too.
- [Amy] Do you too?
- Yeah, you have to pluck away.
There's a carpet up here.
- [Amy] That's not a bad thing.
But yeah, in the nineties
it was kind of tough.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Now everyone's like, you know,
four day work week and do your
eyebrows however you want.
Amazing. Again.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I love it. We're starting
to turn European.
- Amazing.
with this whole... yeah,
I love, I love that vibe.
Yeah. I feel like every
time I go to Europe,
they're always on vacation.
I'm like, "why did I not grow up here?"
- [Amy] Yeah.
- I'm like, what? How are
you still on vacation?
- You should do Kelly Clarkson in Europe.
And then the entire
week should be no shows.
- Yeah. We just sit around
- We just have wine and...
- Will you come to that show
and just hang out with wine?
- Yes. And we walk around and we film it
just one hour a day and you're like,
"This is it." And we're in Europe.
- "And we're done".
And now see us, we're gonna go take a nap.
You teamed up, you said, with
Maya Rudolph for "Baking It."
- [Amy] Yes. Yes, the great Maya.
- [Kelly] For people that don't know,
like what's the premise of
the show other than baking?
- Well, I filled in for the
great Andy Sandberg this year
who was, who did this season last year.
But it's a baking show that's,
it's just goofball city.
It's super fun.
There's a lot of, we do a lot
of singing with each other
around other people.
You know, because I think
I talked to you about this.
I mean, you know, you're the
best singer in the world.
- I'm not, but thank you.
- [Amy] Yes you are.
And don't argue with me. But, um...
- Rude.
- We love singing... rude.
We love singing because, I
love singing because I'm like,
who cares, you know?
- I'm, that's me too.
- I know, but we talked
about this because you...
when you're like, when
you do your soundcheck
you're like, "this matters".
You, you're a professional.
Let me make it clear.
When you're not a professional singer,
you're like, "I don't
know, give it a try."
- Yeah.
- So we goof around a lot.
- Yes.
- And sing a lot and do
a lot of goofball stuff.
- That's great. That's, yeah.
- And then, oh, there's
also a baking competition.
The added experience.
- [Kelly] There's a show.
- There's a show, yeah.
- No, but I love...
so explain the judge...
there's the judges, right?
- Yeah. There's grannys.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- We have grannys who
are the judging panels.
- [Kelly] I love this.
- And they're opinionated
and experienced grannys.
They between them have tons
of years and experience
of cooking and baking and...
- Yeah.
- They're teachers and you know, bloggers
and all this stuff.
But they are, at the end of
the day, they're grandmas.
And so they give it to you straight.
- Yes.
- But they, it's a soft landing.
They give it to you with a lot of love.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah.
And they, they're our judges
and they decide who stays and who goes.
- I love that judging panel.
- [Amy] I know.
- It's amazing.
- [Amy] Me too.
It, it's so fun.
It's so fun to hang out with
Maya. It's so fun to do.
- [Kelly] That's so cool,
those solid relationships.
You'd mentioned that you and Tina and Maya
have known each other for so long.
Having those kind of solid
female relationships for so long.
- [Amy] For sure.
- Kelly] That's incredible.
- [Amy] So many.
- [Kelly] Not everybody has that. Yeah.
- [Amy] So many different
kinds of eyebrows we've had.
- [Kelly] Together!
- [Amy] Together.
- Molding and shaping them together.
- So many. At times just
one. At times just one.
That we all share.
- But just the one uni.
So wait, so you and
Maya have a little song
in the opening credits.
You're speaking about liking to sing.
So I will show a little tape of this. Yes.
- Oh, dear. Well, remember
I'm not a professional.
♪ Baking it ♪
♪ A baking show with hosts you know ♪
♪ Grannies judge and give out dough ♪
♪ Baking it ♪
- Do you want your teeth?
- No, Harriet, I don't.
♪ The bakers bake as tasty teams ♪
♪ On Peacock, give it a stream ♪
♪ Baking it ♪
♪ We're hosting together
for the first time ♪
♪ So who knows what's gonna
impress the grandmas ♪
♪ And what's gonna explode? ♪
(explosion sound effect)
(crowd cheering and applauding)
- [Kelly] So the real question exactly,
the real question here
is what took longer,
learning and writing the
song, or the choreography?
- Oh it's such a good question,
because the choreography we kept...
we kept going, let's
pull it back, like the...
Every time they would do
the the steps we'd be like,
"is there a way where it
could just go like this?"
Like we just kept making
it slower and easier.
- Easier to remember.
- Yeah. So that was the
easiest choreography
we could get them to allow us to do.
- My kind of choreography.
- Me too.
And from SNL you're so used to
just learning choreography
fast, but yet we were still like
(dramatic heavy breathing)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- From the smallest choreography.
- I know. And you're reminded...
that, that happens to me.
When I haven't done a show for a while
and I'm reminded, I'm like, "oh, not 25."
- [Amy] Oh a hundred percent.
- [Kelly] So wait, what's
been your biggest like,
disaster in the kitchen?
Which by the way,
I don't know whose idea
the exploding cake was.
'Cause y'all have the ideas, right?
- Yeah, well we were joking that like
because we had two moms
on the show this year,
We were like, "we're
gonna blow some stuff up".
Like that was our joke. Like baking bad.
- Yeah. Which I love.
- So yeah, so we blew up some stuff.
I have no idea how they did it.
They put something in it
and then just told us to stand back.
- Love.
- Yeah, which is...
But a disaster in the
kitchen? I don't know.
You know, I I, I think that
cooking and baking is like
low risk, high reward.
If it works, you feel
like a million bucks.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And if it doesn't work,
unless it's Thanksgiving, who cares?
- No, this is true.
One time I, I think I've
said this on the show
but one time I made myself a cake
and I just wanted to kinda
be alone on my birthday.
'Cause I was just always around people.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] And I was like, for my birthday,
I just wanna be at my house alone.
- Yes.
I made myself a bread
cake because I looked over
and I was like, "there's the sugar".
And I had forgotten to put it in.
But if you put icing on it...
- [Amy] It tastes fine.
- Totally fine.
- It tastes fine.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I put the icing on it and I
was like, "bread cake is good".
Anyways, so, that's my
big fail. On my birthday.
- It seems like a success
because you were alone.
- It was covered in icing and I was alone.
- [Amy] Yeah. You were alone.
- And watching Family
Feud, living my best dream.
Yeah. It was just easy.
- [Amy] Yeah.
- So wait, you have, I wanted to,
I want to bring this
up because a while ago
you gave a commencement speech at Harvard,
which is incredibly cool.
(audience applauding)
And you said something,
it was really cool.
- Oh my God, yeah.
- So you said
"as you navigate through
the rest of your life,
be open to collaborations.
Other people's ideas are
often better than your own.
Find a group of people who
challenge and inspire you.
Spend a lot of time with them
and it will change your life."
I think this is the best advice.
(audience applauding)
- It's true.
- [Kelly] It is! I... people always,
I don't know if they look and you and go,
"oh my God, your career,
you've done so well".
And I'm like, yeah.
A team of people like, like
there's a whole group of us
that have made all of this happen.
- [Amy] Yeah.
- Like it's so smart to tell people to do.
- I, I think there's...
I think you can do
anything with a good team.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You can do anything.
And a good team is a
team that everyone feels
like they're... they know
what they're working for.
- Yeah.
- [Amy] And also they don't,
there's not a lot of
like, "that's not my job".
A good team is a team that works together.
I've been really lucky in my
life to be on many of them.
- Me too.
- Yeah. And I feel like because of that
I've been able to do all
these different things.
If you have a team of people and it's...
could be your family, your
partner, the people you work with
you have people who know you, support you.
- Yeah.
- [Amy] Care about you...
You can do anything.
And there's no better feeling than like,
failing and successing,
like success and failure with someone.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's so, it feels so
good to win as a team.
- Yeah.
- And it's a lot less lonely when you...
- [Kelly] When you fail.
- When you fail. Yeah.
- [Kelly] And we all do, that's the thing.
I think that people frown
upon it but it's like,
well that's the time I
think you learn the most.
Not when you win. So yeah.
I think that's alright.
- And I think that
working well with others
is a, a really valuable skill.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That I think is really important.
I know it's important with
the people I work with.
That you like to work with other people.
- That's why your shows,
a lot of that is like
your shows that I love watching,
It's always like teams of people
like working together to make
something happen at the end
and there's a product and it's fun.
- Yeah. I think that's why
workplace comedies are fun
is 'cause it's a team of people
that would never choose to be together.
- Yeah.
- And you're like, wow,
we have nothing in common.
Let's make this happen.
- And yet we're succeeding!